hello everyone and welcome to round two
of this year's video World Cup and this
is the game that brought you the big
news gookish enters the world's top 10
and yes he overtakes vishwanathan Anand
as India's new number one or India's
highest rated player after 37 years for
Ananda holding this uh record okay
someone wrote in the comments on Twitter
I did not um uh verify this but I'm sure
it's true I wouldn't lie on the internet
uh Hare Krishna did overtake Anand once
but only in the live rating so while
this is uh definitely true August is uh
currently India number one but also only
in the live ratings if he drops in
rating Below on and uh before the end of
the month then it's not really true so
we'll see how it does but up until then
let's check out the game it's a very
nice one and he finds a very very uh
neat trick to end the game so let's
check it out misrate in iskandarov has
the equalizer he has to win this game to
equalize the match and then the force
tie breaks against gulcash we have E4
Fantasy 5 googlers goes for the Sicilian
Defense Knight F3 Knight to C6 and now
D4 uh Google's going for the so-called
old Sicilian see capture Sunday for
Knight captures and Knight to F6 we have
Knight to C3 and E5 now the Pelican
variation or the sashnikov or the Lasker
variation many names to this one uh
Knight beta knightita B5 and now Pawn to
D6 we have knighted to D5 and now Knight
captures on D5 e captures on D5 and now
Knight the B8 if you remember this is
yes the the exact same position Fabiano
Corona and the Magnus Carlsen had in
their uh 2018 World Series championship
match in London where in some games
Magnus try Knight to be it in some games
he tried Knight D7 uh but um uh all of
the classical games ended in a draw so
here he goes Knights to B8 we have Pawn
to A4 Bishop to E7 and down uh in one of
the games Fabiano caruana in uh uh in
the world's championship match when the
best of day two but here we have Bishop
to D2 still not a new move though it has
been played before we have castles pull
into A5 and now Point pawn to A6 chasing
away the Knight Knight E3 and now Bishop
to F5 again nothing new here we have
Knights the C form uh and now Knight to
D7 now the Knight is coming to C5 and
here there is a game where Bishop T2 was
played but with Bishop to B4 by
mistratin and it is now as of move 14
that we have a completely new game so
okay the D6 Pawn is hanging but Lucas
counters with an attack Rook the C8 now
if the Knight moves then the C2 Pawn
will hang as well so Bishop to E2 we
have Bishop to G6 now preparing Pawn to
F5 and now castles uh googers goes
Knight to C5 with Rook the A3 Now The
Rook can also help out with the defense
along the third rank but also the rule
can be shifted over to try and attack
the black king at some point although
it's very hard to imagine that happening
with this uh bishoping on G6 and now
Ponte f five and if you look at how
nicely gookasha has placed all of his
pieces on such active squares white
didn't really get all that much out of
the opening the Knight is a monster on
C5 the Bishops are nicely placed okay
not incredibly active but you know those
pawns are coming to you for the end F4
or F for at some point so it's going to
be very strong the Rooks also on CNF
files uh the queen still has to figure
out how to get into the game but all in
all a very good position with black for
you know under move 20. uh Knight to B6
going after the Rook also a beautiful
Outpost for the Knight we have rooked to
C7 and now Bishop captures on C5 here my
miseratin says all right my Bishop here
is not nearly as strong as your knight
so let's traded Bishop captures with
Rook captures and now Pawn to B4 uh this
is made possible by uh gookish playing
F5 so the bishop no longer attacks the
C2 Pawn otherwise you would not be able
to do this uh Rook to C7 and now Pawn to
C4 you do not want to despawn being a
Target once F4 is played so Pawn to E4
Forum now you can also see that the
bishop can assume this diagonal and pawn
to F4 now with the Ponte f for the
position either gets blockaded or it
forces gookish to play uh he captures an
F3 Alpha Song which he does you don't
have to do it you could maybe try to
re-maneuver the light Square Bishop over
to add this diagonal somehow or you
could just put the bishop on F6 but he
says no it's time he captures an F3
Alpha saw Bishop captures and now Bishop
to F6 we have King to H1 always a useful
prophylactic move and now Bishop to E5
this is how gookish activates the bishop
but also now makes way for his Queen to
enter the game so you have to be very
very careful here and here yeah uh well
prepares a very nasty trick for Google
she plays Rook D1 and now if Lucas just
goes Queen to H4 which is a very nice
move I'm sure everyone would play this
it would be a problem because then Rook
captures an E5 the captors and then the
Deep Pawn marches forward with the D7
Square being covered the bishop can
enter the game with check uh so you know
very very good position for white if
anything uh it's white who would be
better here so after Rook day one we
have Rook uh C all the way to F7 glucose
just doubles up on the f file he doesn't
fall for this and now Rook 8 to E3 uh
doubling up on the E file with Bishop to
F for chasing away the rook and now
while you could move the Rook um it
doesn't look all that great because if
the Rook moves then Queen to H4 comes
threatens Checkmate and now if you just
want to continue the game you have to
play this ugly H3 move and then after
Queen G3 you have to play King to G1 in
order to avoid Checkmate and then Lucas
can choose uh you know between just
closing of the E file to prevent the
Rooks from infiltrating you could play
Rook to C8 you could go for Queen H2
check immediately and okay it's not a
loss for white but it does look like
something uh very very enjoyable so
instead after Bishop to F4 uh here miss
radin plays Queen to D4 he sacrifices
The Exchange and okay captures it Bishop
captures with Rook characters and now
sorry Network captures Queen characters
and now Pawn to F4 chases away the queen
queen to E6 paralyzes the Rooks here and
the bishop to F5 now chases away the
queen queen back all the way to E2 and
now just Queen to H4 okay now it's not
as dangerous as there is no dark Square
Bishop attacking the H2 Pawn but now
comes King to G1 uh it's uh okay if the
king remains on H1 and let's say you try
something like C5 then G5 can be very
very dangerous G4 and so on now the G5
can be very dangerous in all of the
lines even now after King to H1 you
could still go for G5 but Google doesn't
want to over push it uh no sorry Mr
doesn't want to over push it the king to
G1 is played and now Queen back to F6 uh
you you could like I said uh play a G5
right away Queen to F6 was played and
now Queen to D2 uh putting pressure on
the pawn also defending against Queen to
D4 check Rook the E7 offering a rook
trade as now bookish is up material he
of course wants to trade Rook captures
Queen captures and now Pawn to see 5
finally it happens and okay the material
has been sacrificed but those pawns do
look scary so the captors and now Pawn
to D6 advancing the pawn all the way to
D6 uh gookash of course trades Queens
this comes with checks so Queen E3 check
captures captures and now comes the B
captures on C5 oh sorry F captures on E3
first and B captures on C5 and now the
question is uh can goukash play this is
he better is he worse those pawns really
look scary this Pawn is already on D6 uh
can he do something about this position
uh well in fact he's completely winning
here but you have to find one very very
uh tricky idea so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for gookish and
get him all the way to the world top 10
and India number one uh while I give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
incredible maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
best of the E4 a beautiful centralizing
move by the bishop it guards the B7 Pawn
uh but also it just uh that leaves the
white without a move of course uh first
thing you ask is is the bishop just free
here not really because if the bishop
captures then The Rook controls the
entire file and there is no defense here
you're just gonna play uh Pawn to E2 and
next move you're gonna Queen there is no
stopping this so obviously you cannot
take the bishop so Bishop to G4 is
played and now gokish plays Bishop to D3
he cuts off the white king from uh
entering the position and now e to E1
will be winning of course but here's the
problem and misratin just repeats Bishop
to F3 and now where's the continuation
uh well uh both of them were very low on
time it's like Lucas was maybe some
seven minutes in Stratton had 10 minutes
on the clock E2 is winning here but it's
uh you you still have to grind a lot for
example King to F2 now Bishop to E4 the
bishop now cannot move you're going to
play Caprice and after Bishop captures
you're going to force this Rook versus
knight and the game where white is up
upon and already there's a nasty Pawn on
the uh D6 but still the position is
completely winning for black however it
does look scary and knights are very
tricky bastards so you know anything
could happen but it's instead he repeats
once Bishop to E4 uh with Bishop to G4
and now King to F7 King to F7 means that
gookish calculated everything absolutely
precisely he allowed his clock to go
down to I believe one minute but he
calculates precisely and if he played
King to F7 this means that he will lose
the pawn because Knight the C4 Knight
captures on E3 will happen but this also
means that his King will become
incredibly active and just gobble up all
of these pawns with white having nothing
to do against this so Knight to C4 King
to F6 Knight captures on E3 and now King
to E5 so uh the the line that we've
shown does win by force but if you want
to play against the tricky Knight this
is just going completely winning without
any uh you know trickiness possible
Knight to C4 check uh King to D4 now the
pawns are falling and now Knights the B6
and this is one last trick that uh Mr
Latin tries if the opponent is captured
right away the Knight to D7 check will
cause the gookers The Rook but he
doesn't wander after Knight to B6 he
just plays Bishop to C6 he guards the D7
square and now all of the pawns will
fall even if you play something like 1
to D7 doesn't really matter so it was in
this position and move 44 that miserate
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here gookish wins both
of the games and he goes straight into
round three I don't know if his opponent
is known but I will show at least one
more game from round two and then we
will discuss who plays against who and
other fun stuff so here you resign it's
not it's not as simple as it looks I
will just show you one super super
tricky line uh mistraten decided to call
it a day here but look at this Pawn to
D7 now comes King characters in C5 and
now look at this spawn to H3 you don't
really have an option you can bring your
king into the game so you might as well
create some uh breathing room for the
king king B5 you go after the a pawn now
Knight to C8 and now look at this King
characters on A5 Knight to D6 you are
planning to play Knights the E8 to
prevent The Rook from going to d8 and
then you will uh be a threatening
promotion King the B4 and now Knight to
E8 and now you are threatening to bring
the queen into the game but it doesn't
matter because here you will just play
Bishop captures on D7 and after Bishop
captures yes you do have two pieces for
The Rook but look at this Rook to F7
attacks the bishop and now what do you
play you cannot go over on this diagonal
uh so you might as well just move away
Bishop to G4 or anywhere it doesn't
really matter and now King the C5 taking
away the D6 Square from the White Knight
and now the White Knight is stuck there
on E8 and you're just gonna push your a
pawn to Victory it's actually that
simple so what you could do is I'm like
King H2 let's say A5 even if Bishop to
E6 then you just go for the double
attack you win material if not Bishop T6
then you really have nothing okay the
bishop could help out with uh against
the pawn but I mean you have other
points you can push and the Knight is
stuck here the Knight is not going
anywhere for the for the rest of the
game as it's on a light square and
everyone knows if the Knight is on a
light Square the only Square for you to
go to is a dark Square which doesn't
really help you as you only have a light
Square Bishop to protect the Knight so I
mean very very tricky stuff but
obviously yeah miserating calculated at
all and decided to call it a day here so
after Bishop to C6 bookish enters the
top 10 and he's the new Indian number
one but like I said only in the only in
the live ratings so if he gets um you
know a weaker opponent in the next round
maybe he gets a draw or maybe he even
loses then he will probably again drop
it below so we'll have to wait until the
end of the tournament and who knows if
he will be playing anything else after
the tournament for uh for the entire
month but yeah good stuff these are the
new rankings on the world top ten this I
took this screenshot at the moment that
bookish ended his game so it could be
even different now but I I don't think
it is so there you have it Magnus uh
Magnus carwana uh he caught with in in
third world champion dingler and in
fourth yeah
and now in number nine it is good cash
but also in number 10 it is vishwanathan
so even by losing his spot to gukash
island is still in the in the world's
top 10.
Dominguez Perez
and so on and so on so yeah brilliant
stuff by by Young only 17 years old and
already in the top 10 absolutely
brilliant uh so you know all the best to
him I would like to thank Seth Harper
schlerter Paul Harris Aaron is the best
wife and Richard Schwartz for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day